welcome to this sorry rapid game let's
get going Tim mm-hmm I've played them
before in this rep a poor one win okay
hmm yeah I wonder there's something else
that I can try besides my usual 93 can
go for the field shadow system but Samar
that's really not my my usual my usual
line ok so again the group that I've
studied this system a bit a couple of
month ago now black column is okay in
that line but that is some pretty much
true for the whole gruene far away so if
you don't have a brilliant line against
this opening it's just the same for all
of the top players um c5 is actually not
that great i believe
okay let's take it Queen 85 now it's the
only real move down so cd5 he will play
evil bear play 9525 bishops III can't
cook c1 and now black has a choice I
mean okay like can't play that it's not
terrible but I think I'm castles is
probably a little bit more solid down
yeah now d takes you form is the move
that black normally chooses night efore
is also possible has been played by
Kasparov and Fisher but nowadays is a
little bit under cloud CD 593 22 seems
to be better for white with them yeah
more than one line actually there is
also castles but that seems a bit a bit
dicey maybe yeah that is done the solid
move take him and now black has to
Castle first if he goes Quincy 595 wins
immediately it's a little little trap
and if gave that happens this game will
end relatively quickly as white is
threatening Bosh with both both both
Bishop Bishop takes of seven winning the
Queen and night c7 so Quincy 595 is just
ending the game has happened in in in
strong players games yeah here White has
mostly to move Knight to f3 or 922 932
is the
a line but I don't know it I simply
don't know it and I have studied Knight
f3 so I'm going to go for that yeah now
why it has this um this annoying 95
ideas so yeah exactly like normally um
moves the Queen again capsules as it
happens quite often in the Greenfeld and
can be a little bit of a memory contest
yeah
what did I look at here what's that was
it 23 we need to or age 30
well I absolutely cannot remember 32
there was an idea with age three ng form
well okay yes let's think about it is it
Queenie true here really
or h3 I wonder about night h5 if this is
some an option after Queenie too but I
think Bishop g5 is probably probably
okay h6 Bishop H form g5 might even have
92 then okay that's a tricky business or
is it age 3 in this position I don't
really know it might be a transposition
of a play in three is e five something
that might happen now you have to play
over the board against the goon felt
it's a bad idea it should really know
what's going on I don't remember i'm
playing Queenie to hear but it might as
well be that this age 3 is right h3
gives me some additional age 2 square
Bishop f5 alright but Queenie to is a
move definitely Queenie to Bishop f5
rugby one night if ye goes for 85 so
maybe I made a mistake how may be so
Bishop g5 I cannot play I have to go to
g3 Bishop g5 this a 4-hour wait i can
actually play it Bishop g5 we form
Bishop f6 ef3 Queen f3 and I'm
protecting this this makes Bishop g5
from a clear candidate as some it would
give me additional ideas of taking
whatever 6i putting in knight on d5 in
general White's players based on his
better development
Bishop g5 v for Bishop of 6ef Queen
takes her there's no problem there it's
just a pawn so and Bishop g5 is probably
stronger than Bishop d3 night h5 is that
an idea when I got 95 then at age five
is a strange move anyway just to avoid
the capture but I am it's not that big a
deal oh not quite sure what what what he
should play now what move it's not clear
to me he will avoid not working Bishop
g4 this age three and I'm probably just
better yeah I guess so h three maybe
four as a move but takes on g4 ticks hmm
let's quite strange okay be sure before
I can everything else fails i can take
f6 Bishop f5 um Bishop f5
he goes them ok so now h3 which looks
totally normal there's night this afore
I am that's a a bit of a problem
so I have to take I guess and now no
it's interesting i have Bob bishop f6 is
forced and it takes this time though so
now I have 95 i also have 94 and i have
h 3l h 3 is just just going to be a good
good move I guess well where's he going
to f5 he gets kicked again there should
be six is entirely off I would take it
plain I to you for that sir strategic
wind almost Bishop to d7 runs into root
d1 okay not terrible but it's a temple
and also an additional idea is always 94
and then possibly to c5 so if I go what
Bishop d7 maybe like rook g1 rookie 890
form something like that now that looks
pretty ok that looks ok 44 white maybe
Bishop f5 is an option simply intending
to provoke a form so that the night may
hop to deform for some counterplay ideas
after Bishop f5 I have a a couple of
options though I can also donate d2 492
for next quite interesting yeah I think
why there's definitely a bit better here
even though I had to give up the bishop
pair but f6 that bishop on f6 is just
not very good and the weakness there on
d5
the d5 square and the open very open
long diagonal be three over to f7 this
term can be a problem
yeah it's not an easy decision
especially I am sorry especially Bishop
f5 comes into consideration I can even
consider to go g4 after Bishop f5 that's
not that's not completely completely off
yeah if she takes on f3 Equis takes is a
temple and Queen on f3 is also lining up
together with the bishop on b3 on that
f7 pawn that's a very uncomfortable
position note how important it is really
that the pawn is only five if the Pawn
black spawn would be on e6 which is okay
pure purely theoretical discussion it
never could have been like that out of
this opening here but just imagine black
spawn being only six then black will
probably just take on f3 drop Bishop
back to e7 or something and then it's
it's totally ok for him it's symmetrical
and nothing particularly happening yeah
and I said even g4 is interesting here
it's really interesting as if he goes
efore yeah I go 92 and just win that
pawn and that's no real compensation for
black so g4 he has to move that bishop
again that's very tempting 'if was also
interesting definitely but the night
only four can be a real real interesting
um i DM
however efore Bishop d7 let's say nine
to five Bishop g7 ax it's not so clear
what I'm doing after that it looks very
nice but what is my actual plane on the
other hand g4 he might have aged five at
some point but if it's difficult to do
her black ok let's do it if he goes
efore I have 92 and win the e4 pawn some
that's not that's not happening unless
he decides to just yet on the heck with
it and activate the bishop there on g7
but it's it's never going to be full
compensation Bishop d7 is very likely to
happen and then I was thinking proly
rook t1 rook ft 190 for also comes into
consideration of course
Bishop d7 rook fd1 rook 88 probably huh
red star it's still fairly so later it's
not like he's falling apart quickly
some 94-94 here maybe my t6 can be real
nuisance or give one food Jim it's it's
still a rapid game let's do it come on
bring that look into the game it's it's
very unlikely to be a bad move let's say
maybe it's not the absolute best move
but it's not a bad move pretty sure
about that so the question is am I going
to play yeah there's actually giving up
on covering that f7 pawn and this can be
a factor let's check on that I can try
94 95 very very direct approach nightly
for Bishop e7 there should be seven
95 that's a good that's good let's do
that and just let's just start with the
story I still have some other ideas I
can also go after Bishop e7 I can do
something like rook g5 as well rook g5
of cd1 but 95 actually looks looks good
95 let F to G 5 so that Queen f3 as an
additional idea let's do that come on
who isn't sorry for my voice there yeah
Bishop e8 Queen f3 and yes to he has to
take that Bishop at night otherwise f7 s
going to go into collapse
this is why I always thought rook ad aid
instead of rook ft 8 or thought that
black hats too um Kevin f7 a little bit
at Bishop f4 system against the
Greenfeld is a pretty decent choice if
you want to save line it's it's against
the group felt is difficult to find a
line that it's um just playing for two
results yeah where you can press a
little bit without any risk the Bishop
f4 line comes close to that it's um it's
relatively it's relatively solid in
sound and still carries a little bit of
punch so um Queen f3 or it says
something better Queenie ax three is
good that's not let's not be too
sophisticated here that is just a good
move I think
f7 i think it probably has to take that
on g5 and then play em yeah quick Quincy
7 after which um there's a number of
interesting options simplest probably
being Nigel back to e4 and then sinking
the knight to f6 it's not clear that
this sum is so fantastic but check it
looks okay that's probably an
accommodating that he treats this or is
rook da de défense actually no official
said no so that's not really happening
so then then rook takes the one cannot
help him it's very hard to believe on
the other hand it's not clear if there
is some way to benefit so Bishop g5 95
Quincy 7 is there is there something
great that I can do
don't see it
yeah probably night back to you for then
so neither six I really don't see how
else to make any headway twin g3 is
interesting though for Queen H form that
is an interesting move yeah so we have
to take before we automatically
recapture let's think for one moment I
wonder now look t7 as a flashy moves but
I don't think it's working he can play
the Chevy 7 back otherwise interesting
ok so Quincy seven will happen so
so it's Queen g3n adium for Queen edge
form it's definitely not bad Queen v3
Queen g3 how is he defending against the
screen age for business kingi seven
maybe tweenage 4-h 694 and it's never
never really great from it it's always
always a bit of suffering still it's not
so easy to determine what's the what the
best yeah how I'm make him suffer the
most now simply 94 is definitely not bad
either Queen g3 group the aid kicks it
squinting now Queen g3 King g7 and
that's really the only only defense them
oh he's a [ __ ] distance 96 but I
don't see a tactic to use it Queen h4h
694 maybe even queen is severus player I
mean it's not great but it might be just
about ok right that is good for y now
there's a couple of good options Queen
f6 also looks kind of attractive
threatens 96 that's a nice thread
actually Queen have six let's say he
does a stupid move 86 can f 96 and win
every Bishop takes bishop sm group d7
and black resigns
but Queen f6 es group d 8 and after that
hmm I have no real real great move
the 898 passive but it seems to hold
94 up the 89 f6 check king okay come on
let's do it maybe I missed something
here but okay it's really too hard to
not drink anything someone recently sent
me a message that those changes sounds
of a problem yeah I understand that is
irritating but I really have to drink
something 20 minutes of non-stop talking
when it is pretty hot outside so what is
he going to play
it's roughly eight playable in the first
in the first place now I have six check
King g8 and sorry night look the 896 jay
king g 7 28 28 yeah might be I mean then
after g5 I'm in good shape um ok Knight
f6
I df6 looks very normal King g7 I wonder
then that none this ninety five foot
four possible 97 okay let's do it and I
can store a thing of alternatives
yeah 95 the scootin Queen g5 is just 97
94th of her falls apart so we cannot go
there and where is he going actually
after 95 mm so it sucked them to have
need maybe doesn't that doesn't look
very attractive after King g7 say
anything else g5 there's roop da yeah
that that leads nowhere so over here and
if he goes let's say to g5 then 97 wins
outright Luke hanks and after move from
98 Queen f7 and he resigns he has to
keep f7 I think covered somehow so yeah
maybe quindi aid even though that looks
scary
quindi head looks really scary but maybe
I don't have fun convincing move against
that it pretty much has to go to da de
or f8 okay evade but then Queen Queen f6
looks very scary yeah so it should be he
went there night see so what am I not
seeing here
yeah that's his happen there is no
intermediate move okay
after 28 I didn't have a clear way I
think I didn't see a clear way certainly
a couple of ways to improve the position
because black is I mean pretty much um
tied down but probably no clear way of
really am reviewed that maybe age for
would have been an idea yeah Queenie ate
an age form cannot take because of 9780
I'm intending g 59 f six maybe I mean
black is under under quite substantial
pressure some
yeah they simply as no move now
it's always checking 98 check Queen f7
chick he loses the house now
and the Bishop f4 line is something that
it's a pretty save option but black had
some ways to equalize for sure but term
it's um it's a good alternative for
white players who wander relatively
simple save approach to the Greenfeld
which is difficult to come by there are
many very sharp lines and it's not so
much a problem that they are sharp it's
the problem is that they are sharp and
quite often don't lead to anything like
it's quite often just actively placed
and in those sharp main lines so
sometimes it's not a bad idea against
such a forcing sharp opening as a
Greenfeld to find something relatively
safe because very often them quite often
the black players who are looking for a
dynamic struggle their name on the other
hand struggle with the slowish slowish
am types of from games and well here
this is this this open variation with c5
and so on it's not particularly dull but
it's something that if you are well
prepared with wide you can basically
play without risking Aladdin resides
yeah and with good reason yeah so let's
have a look at this as I said this is
ohm this is a theoretical position and
here I really wasn't sure if if if you
start Queenie two more h3i and really
could remember so I went with this night
age five might be an argument against my
move it's it's really really possible I
wasn't sure and I didn't want to spend
even more time there i was thinking
Bishop g5 could be okay got something
like this I don't know here I might have
this move I know sorry if he takes this
is sorry he is covering them so net d2
is not even possible look do you want is
however possibility
quite funny okay UND five I don't really
believe in that move so much either you
think he's got some problems now with
those light squares and Bishop g4 is
probably giving me a bit too much and
the engine also gives the capture I
pretty much have to wear age three I
would like to play the book but he's got
a four and this is not mean this is not
losing material quickly but definitely
not what I want h3 has to be preempted
by the capture first then aged three
yeah and now he's sitting there with a
with the choice that's not very
comfortable yeah if we start with the
ugliest move this is leading to a
strategic disaster yeah those pawns are
terribly weak and this is an eternal
night fantastic position Quincy Falls
probably even winning stuff there are
only six yeah and it will be that's
totally rubbish so um what did he do he
went here right yeah so Bishop d7 that
was what i expected most and i was
thinkin here brooke d 8 and 94 or 95
that's difficult to say would have been
interesting to figure out I was thinking
94 but the engine actually gives 95 as
better yeah interesting they're always
tactics and like this move bush yeah it
is quite a lot of stuff is hanging here
White's pieces are super active so
Bishop g7 and then 95 is interesting
putting pressure here and then tending
94 yeah that's huge pressure with pieces
the engine is giving what I've written
already one point
7 wow it looks dangerous I still thought
he would go back this but he went to f5
and I put out g4 yeah and now yeah he
has to go Bishop d7 there's really not
much else or bishop CA engine gives
bishop CA it yeah not a good sign so
yeah II 492 one that that's just giving
me that pawn so that cannot be greater
Bishop back and just took the 1-yard
engine agrees and now it wants to play
Bishop c8 and this is yeah exactly our
plate completely if I followed the
engineer basically here Queen III jack
takes takes takes takes here 94 both I'm
playing pure engine rules here that's
cool maybe I'm getting reported him
check King do so okay now the engine
wants to go g5 and not 95 mm I couldn't
really I wasn't sure if maybe if after
that if I'm having some such such a
great continuation the engine gives this
with a friend with 1.8 that's quite a
bit I mean black is pretty much
paralyzed that that's true i mean it
doesn't have anything great that you can
do computer already wants to do stuff
like this check and the wide winds
basically is that really already
necessary I mean it's possible I have
this this kind of idea and what what is
black doing against it hmm and sometimes
I can take on yet queen of six check
yeah g5 is probably probably really
strong
but ok was that bad okay g5 is stronger
and he has to go to d8 here yeah
probably I'm winning I'm gaining some
time with the media g5 I was thinking
Queen d8 only move and then I was
thinking age formed and tending g5 and
then Knight f6 again he has this however
and this idea okay that that helps them
quite a bit the engine goes down to
almost equal you know what does it give
additionally this move yeah this is
something that I also had considered
intending g5 mmm mattg high for stronger
it was really stronger him I did not
really appreciate how good that is I
mean it is clear that white is in
command but it's really is really awful
it's really awful for like jump or put
them in just taking material yeah that's
that's very that's a very frustrating
move attacking here here yeah something
like this is check just winning winning
stuff quite nice yeah okay so he went to
g5 though after which night c7 just
winced house after move check yeah I'm
shy and winning everything yeah that was
a nice wind out of the out of the
gruenfelder Bishop f4 line as I said
it's an interesting line for white
players looking for something relatively
risk cream okay well thanks for watching